[VOCALIZING] (SINGING) E.
[LAUGHS]
(SPEAKING) Instead of (SINGING) E.
I'm Christina Aguilera.
Over the next 30 days,
I'm going to walk
you step by step
through what it takes
to be a great singer, including
a personal warm-up routine I've
crafted just for you.
[VOCALIZING]
You'll learn my best techniques
for elevating your singing
and stage presence, how
to emotionally connect
to what you're singing,
what to listen for in a song
and make it your own, and
lastly, how to develop a vision
and perform a song
that is truly yours.
Everything should just
be a feeling and a flow.
You're going to walk away
knowing how to perform
your own rendition of a song.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]